well forecasters are calling Florence's
storm surge life-threatening Adriana
Diaz is in Jacksonville North Carolina
where there's also been significant
storm surge overnight and Adriana that
is what people are most alarmed about
right now that storm surge
that's right bianna we are 20 miles
inland from the Atlantic and we are
still getting clobbered out here storm
surge is a major concern because
Jacksonville is on a river that leads
into an inlet that's on the Atlantic so
that Atlantic water surges it's going to
push inland 20 miles to where we are
we're also dealing with rain rain has
topped already 10 inches in Jacksonville
and the wind speeds at their peak right
now the wind gusts are about 80 miles an
hour
we are told trees are down we spoke to
some electrical workers who are actually
staying at our hotel and they said they
believe those downed trees have knocked
the power out we lost power here at our
hotel last night before it even got this
bad and so they are standing by for the
wind to die down if you can see their
trucks are back there that's what they
call line trucks or bucket trucks that's
what they use to restore the power but
they are not going anywhere until this
wind dies down and they can go out there
safely
so right now conditions are not good in
Jacksonville but rescue teams are still
making rescues John I'm going to toss it
back to you grounded thanks wait just
one of the reasons we're not able to
talk to Jeff is in Wilmington they've
set a record it's 91 miles an hour's of
gusting of the wind that's faster than
86 miles an hour from hurricane Fran and
also faster than Hurricane Floyd in 1999
so that's why there's a big problem
there